E
TOMORROW.
♪ ♪
>> Laura: I'M LAURA INGRAHAM,
THIS IS "THE INGRAHAM ANGLE."
WE HAVE A HUGE SHOW FOR YOU
TONIGHT, A LOT GOING ON IN
WASHINGTON AND BEYOND THE LET'S
DIVE RIGHT IN.
IT'S TIME TO PUT AMERICANS
FIRST, THAT'S THE FOCUS OF
TONIGHT'S ANGLE.
OUR ELITES IN POLITICS AND THE
MEDIA, THEY REALLY WANT YOU TO
KNOW THAT THEY CARE DEEPLY ABOUT
THE AFGHAN PEOPLE SO MUCH THAT
THEY WANT TO BRING AS MANY
AFGHANS HERE TO THE
UNITED STATES AS POSSIBLE.
>> ACCEPTING AFGHAN REFUGEES AND
THE WILLINGNESS TO ACCEPT MORE
BECAUSE WE HAVE TO DO MORE.
>> THE INTEGRATION OF REFUGEES,
IN PARTICULAR IT'S BEEN A GREAT
AMERICAN SUCCESS STORY.
WE ARE ACTUALLY QUITE GOOD AT IT
HERE IN AMERICA, 50,000 AFGHAN
REFUGEES IN THE NATION, OVER
300 MILLION IS NOT EVEN A DROP
IN THE BUCKET.
>> ACROSS THE UNITED STATES, WE
ARE SEEING WIDESPREAD SUPPORT
FOR AFGHAN REFUGEES, BUT FOR
REFUGEE RESETTLEMENT IN GENERAL.
>> Laura: WHILE IT IS
CERTAINLY HEART WRENCHING TO SEE
THE NEEDLESS SUFFERING WHEREVER
IT OCCURS IN THE WORLD, IT'S
JUST AWFUL, NONE OF US WANT TO
SEE THAT.
BUT WHY IS IT THAT MOST OF THE
SAME PEOPLE YOU JUST SAW IN
THOSE CLIPS AND ALL THESE
POLITICIANS, ALL THE PEOPLE
GOING ON AND ON ABOUT LETTING
EVERYBODY IN THE COUNTRY, WHY
ARE THEY SO OFTEN IGNORE THE
VERY REAL SUFFERING HERE AT
HOME?
YOU DON'T HAVE TO GO TO THE
AFGHAN PROVINCES NEAR BOB GRAHAM
TO SEE TRAGEDY.
YOU CAN SEE IT NOT FAR FROM
HERE IN BALTIMORE.
IN THE LAST THREE WEEKS, FIVE
TEENAGERS HAVE BEEN SHOT THERE,
TWO OF THEM FATALLY.
115-YEAR-OLD WAS GUNNED DOWN IN
THE STREET
BROAD DAYLIGHT.
IF YOU DON'T HAVE TO GO TO
THOUSANDS LIVING IN VIOLENCE.
YOU CAN GO TO CHICAGO TO SEE
THAT.
16 WERE SHOT YESTERDAY ALONE,
INCLUDING A 7-YEAR-OLD BOY WHO
WAS SITTING IN THE BACK OF HIS
MOM'S CAR.
IT'S ALL HORRIFYING, BUT WE
SHOULDN'T BE SURPRISED.
WHEN THE TALIBAN TERRORIZES
AFGHANS, IT'S AN ISLAMIC
FUNDAMENTALIST EXTREMIST CULT
AFTER ALL, COME ON.
IF BUT WHAT'S OUR EXCUSE?
WHY AREN'T WE MORE SHOCKED?
WIRED WE DEMANDING A RESPONSE TO
THE GANGS AND THE CARTELS, THE
OPIOIDS, ALL OF IT TERRORIZING
OUR NEIGHBORHOODS HERE AT HOME?
IN FACT, THE LEFT IS ONLY MADE
MATTERS WORSE ON THE GROUND FOR
THE WORKING CLASS HERE AT HOME.
THEY EXCUSE RIOTS, THEY BAILED
OUT CRIMINALS, THEY ENDORSED THE
RACIST, RADICAL AGENDA OF BLM,
AND DEMOCRATS AND BETTER, THE
LEFT, ON ALL OF THE ISSUES OF
COURSE, THEY'VE HELPED MAKE ALL
THINGS WORSE AT EVERY TURN.
EVERY PERSON NOW DEMANDING THAT
WE TAKE EVERY AFGHAN BECAUSE WE
PROMISED THEM FORGETS THAT
AMERICA'S FIRST PROMISE IS TO
HER OWN CITIZENS.
THEIR SAFETY, THEIR SECURITY,
AND THEIR FREEDOM.
YET OUR BORDER TOWNS ARE BEING
OVERRUN BY RELEASED MIGRANTS
BECAUSE BIDEN REFUSES TO DO
WHAT'S RIGHT ON THE BORDER.
THEY KNOW THAT COVID-INFECTED
MIGRANTS WILL INFECT AMERICAN
CITIZENS AND SCHOOLCHILDREN THIS
FALL, THEY KNOW CRIME IS GOING
TO SPIKE DUE TO THE MILLION PLUS
MIGRANTS BIDEN HAS ALREADY
RELEASED INTO THE COUNTRY.
AND THEY DON'T CARE.
IN FACT, THEIR GOAL RIGHT NOW IS
TO SPEED UP THE ADMISSION OF
THESE MIGRANTS INTO THE
UNITED STATES.
JUST YESTERDAY THE
ADMINISTRATION ANNOUNCED NEW
RULES TO EMPOWER BUREAUCRATS WHO
WILL NOW UNILATERALLY DECIDE
WHETHER AN ILLEGAL ALIEN SHOWS
UP AT OUR BORDER, SHOULD BE
ALLOWED ENTRY INTO THE
UNITED STATES.
THESE OPEN BORDERS FANATICS
CANNOT BE TRUSTED TO SAFEGUARD
OUR SOVEREIGNTY AND ENFORCE OUR
LAWS.
IT'S BEEN OBVIOUS FOR A LONG
TIME THAT WHEN YOU REALLY THINK
ABOUT IT, THE ELITES HAVE PRETTY
MUCH HAD IT WITH AMERICANS.
THEY ARE LIKE CHINA -- REMEMBER
REGULAR AMERICANS, THEY ELECTED
TRUMP.
THEY LOVE THEIR SECOND AMENDMENT
STILL AND THEY ARE FAR TOO
RELIGIOUS AND AT THEIR CORE,
THEY COME FROM A KIND OF EVIL
AND RACIST BACKGROUND.
THUS, THE MORE FOLKS FROM OTHER
COUNTRIES WHO CAN COME HERE, THE
BETTER.
EVEN IF WE CAN'T REALLY THAT
THEM, EVEN IF THEY BECOME WARDS
OF THE STATE, EVEN IF THEY BRING
IN MORE CRIME, MORE VIOLENCE,
THEIR EXTENDED FAMILY COMES IN,
THIRD COUSINS TWICE REMOVED.
THE LEFT, TO THE OPEN BORDERS
ESTABLISHMENT, THEY ARE BETTER
THAN THE OLD NORMAL.
THE NEXT THREE YEARS WILL SEE
BLUNDER AFTER BLUNDER FROM BIDEN
AS HIS TEAM DRIFTS FROM ONE
CRISIS TO THE NEXT.
SO WHAT SHOULD CONSERVATIVES IN
POWER DO NOW?
WELL, FIRST THING WE SHOULD DO
IS RESIST THE DEMOCRATS STANDING
BINGE -- SPENDING BINGE THAT'S
HAPPENING.
THAT'S GOING TO BE WASTED
BECAUSE BIDEN'S TEAM ARE NOT
COMPETENT ADMINISTRATORS.
SECOND THING WE SHOULD DO,
DEFEND THE STATES WERE TRYING TO
DO THE RIGHT THING.
RED STATES ARE LEADING THE WAY
ECONOMICALLY AND THEY ARE
LEADING THE WAY TO HELP PROTECT
OUR CHERISHED FREEDOMS.
WE CANNOT LET BIDEN BULLY THEM
OR THE INEPT BLUE STATE LEADERS
DRAG THEM DOWN.
AND THIRD, I THINK WE SHOULD
OBVIOUSLY PROTECT OUR BORDER.
THE G.O.P. MAY BE DIVIDED IN THE
IMMIGRATION AMNESTY ISSUE
REFUGEES, BUT WE SHOULD AGREE ON
THE RULE OF LAW AND RESIST ALL
IMMIGRATION ACTIONS THAT ARE NOT
IN STRICT ACCORDANCE WITH DULY
PASSED LAWS.
AND FOURTH, OF COURSE, WE HAVE
TO FIGHT INFLATION.
THAT INCLUDES PRESSURING THE
FEDERAL RESERVE TO TAKE MORE
AGGRESSIVE ACTION TO STOP
INFLATION AND BLOCK DISASTROUSLY
BIG SPENDING BILLS.
NUMBER FIVE, WE SHOULD CONTINUE
TO BEAT THE DROP FOR ENERGY
INDEPENDENCE.
WE DID IT UNDER TRUMP, IT WAS
AWESOME.
WE CAN DO IT AGAIN.
LOWER ENERGY PRICES MEAN MORE
PROSPERITY.
IT MEANS MORE JOBS FOR ALL
AMERICANS.
SIXTH, WE HAVE TO TRY TO WIN IN
EVERY STATE, HOW ABOUT THAT
CONCEPT?
BECAUSE FOR THE LAST 25 YEARS,
REPUBLICANS HAVE FOCUSED ON
WINNING THE MAJORITY BY
CAPTURING A SLIM NUMBER OF RED
STATES AND THEN PICKING UP FEW
PURPLE STATES HERE AND THERE.
IT'S REALLY HARD TO DO.
AND THAT STRATEGY, AS WE SAW,
HAS FAILED, AND ITS ALLOW THE
HARD LEFT TO BUILD SOLID SUPPORT
ON THE TWO COASTS THAT THEY
DOMINATE NOW.
THAT CAN'T STAND.
FOR ALL THEIR PROBLEMS,
CALIFORNIA AND NEW YORK ARE TOO
IMPORTANT TO CONCEDE TO THE
LEFT.
IF THEY ARE BOTH BEAUTIFUL,
GREAT STATES.
WE'VE GOT TO WIN THEM BACK.
IF WE REALLY WANT TO STOP THE
SOCIALISTS WHO DESPISE OUR
COUNTRY, WANT TO DESTROY OUR
COUNTRY, WANT TO IMPORT MORE
PEOPLE INTO OUR COUNTRY TO KIND
OF BALANCE OUT OR SWAMP THE OLD
NORMAL, WE HAVE TO SEE SOME BIG
LANDSLIDES.
REMEMBER, REAGAN FOUGHT FOR
EVERY STATE AND EVENTUALLY WON
49 OF THEM.
WE HAVE TO TRY TO DO THE SAME.
THE TIME IS RIGHT TO TAKE OUR
RELIGIOUS FREEDOM, OUR MESSAGE
OF FREEDOM AND PROSPERITY TO THE
VOTERS ON TWO COASTS, INTO THE
INNER CITIES, YOU BET, THEY HAVE
TO HEAR OUR MESSAGE TOO.
PEOPLE ARE SUFFERING THERE FROM
LEADERSHIP.
THEY ARE DYING THERE BECAUSE OF
INCOMPETENT LEADERSHIP.
IF WE MUST LIVE THROUGH A REPEAT
OF THE 1970s WITH BIDEN, LET'S
TRY